but you know famous last words dude I
thought 69 was going away forever true
if someone is goofy lawyer on Instagram
yeah what the [ __ ] is that man that she
cuffs up on my Explorer page all the
time knowing lawyer for the people or
whatever and it's like a paneled video
where like the lower left one is like a
little description yeah top one is a
picture of our Kelly and then it's like
yeah half the screen is him talk it's
like so what he was saying and I'm I
know we got some lawyer ass listeners
out there so [ __ ] lawyer ass lookin
ass [ __ ] feel free to correct my stupid
ass I know we got some lawyer ass we got
asked lawyer ass law as [ __ ] any
lawyers in the audience than ia
so you know when you be doing an Iraq
and um you know it's a it's like [ __ ]
its acronym like breaking down a case
okay okay yeah I went to business school
next show yeah I took some law classes
nice Coletti does just poison me with
that voice anyway yeah he so he said
that so he's he's breaking down
basically that's six nine he still could
do time he's trying to say that the
government was saying they wouldn't
pursue any charges and they would they
wouldn't it was something like that the
government wouldn't advise doing time or
something like that but he's he's
basically saying that the judge I
believe still has the option to give him
time okay so the government like the
federal government is offering up a
recommendation like okay he's gonna
snitch we recommend no time I see okay
and the judge could still be like no how
about five which I hope happens that'd
be crazy
damn that'd be crabby crazy also
appointed
so I'd be crazy someone pointed out if
he does the full 47 he would get out
when he's 69 I know I know dude that
would be poetry yeah that I feel like
the judge has to do it there's like I
know that the FBI recommended that or a
zero years because of the quality of the
information that you've provided and
everything and you know it seems like in
the past year maybe you have changed a
little bit
cut the hair everything you know these
are these are good indications but I
just I can't pass up this joke that's a
really good bit and so I'm gonna give
you 47 years
[ __ ] memed on memed bits get memes
dude good trick shot at nerd 47 years
bust that down Tatiana bust that one
down huh
47 years on the gang ohoo literally
literally hang good luck in there I
guess it's no gang because you aren't in
one anymore maybe this is on God shitty
Twitter account as a lawyer or a judge
like some shitty old judge is gonna be
relatable 47 years on god Oh bang ooh
not lit not lit so not lit that's awful
uh [ __ ] boy judge ah
that's game you're gonna do 47 years
without me female defendant walks in
yeah it's like a damaged one of those
teachers that sleeps with her students
you know damn like so no hug for me or
what
[Laughter]
so like we have all these records of you
texting your students but it's like why
didn't I get a text you know a Consuela
did you I hit the showers today without
me all right whatever
for years bangs the gobble you have a
whatever the [ __ ]
but like conjugal visits are still cool
listen here I'm gonna give you like 40
years but I wanna let you get conjugal
because like you deserve a body like
that is so sick like I couldn't just see
it right away you know I'm saying oh my
god so like once I'm done with this
ruling I give you another kind of ruler
you know I'm saying you just like Bart
he say was the [ __ ] wire judge is so
whack court adjourned
oh [ __ ] Johnny just pulls up to the
courtroom yo what's good what do we got
here there really is no like Trent like
that's gonna be the new should some a
trendy judge yeah yeah yeah the next
like big like political thing yeah I
mean hot judge now that like you know
weird like hypebeast [ __ ] boy kids are
like infiltrating gaming and like air
all these other weird it's just gonna be
like the lawyers and the accountants now
that's next that's gonna be like the hot
[ __ ] to be yeah you know yeah like after
being a youtuber and the gamer and
everything like that it's like washed
because that's so what every kid wants
to do now yeah I want to be YouTube or
whatever it's not be the hipster if the
cool thing is gonna be account
accountants yeah be talk by accountants
you know behind-the-scenes [ __ ] and now
that's when it's gonna happen
boy mailman
exactly yeah I got something for your
slot for your box baby slide in that
thing yeah I go down on box all day I'm
saying maybe you could open up yours one
time huh text you before he gets there
I'm coming through what why are you
texting
what's your a D again no what what wait
it's on the envelope a hat what how did
you get my number [ __ ] is this
that's another like straitlaced as job
with a [ __ ] boy and B so funny
[ __ ] boy judges for a solid [ __ ] boy
lawyer now I mean there are definitely
[ __ ] white lawyers though yeah yeah
what's like some gum [ __ ] boy TSA there
you go yeah there it is yeah mm-hmm
huh so like what kind of search do you
want to do today I patted you down maybe
I got some [ __ ] on me yeah yeah maybe
there's dangerous chemicals in my body
do you want to find out ooh you want
swab my mouth I don't know that's not a
flex